Amina pour vous c'est un problème de
racisme
euh je avant de répondre à cette
question permettez-moi de présenter
d'abord mes condoléances à toutes les
familles en dei parce que cet événement
a donné une dimension euh à la
communauté africaine vivant en France et
même dans les pays d'origine puisque le
corps des enfants euh et des frères et
sœurs de Fatou sont attendus par tout le
Mali et on pense en faire des
funérailles national parce que tant des
enfants 14 enfants du coup le Mali n'a
jamais connu ça dans de tel DRAM vous me
parler du racisme je dirais qu'il y a le
racisme parce que moi j'ai connu la
France dent temp des années 70 qui est
complètement différente de la France
d'aujourd'hui la France des années 70
moi quand je suis arrivée adolescente
que j'étais j'avais l'âge de 13 ans j'ai
fait le collège en France entouré adoré
par des Français de souche j'ai fait le
lycée entouré adoré par des Français fr
de souche j'ai fait la fac enterré et
adoré par des Français de souche mais la
France d'aujourd'hui je me retrouve pas
dedans je me retrouve pas tant
elle est devenue austère tant elle est
devenue méconnaissable pour des raisons
que je m'explique parce que j'ai vécu
toute les crises économiques en France
j'ai vécu la transformation de la
société française je j'ai tout
simplement un message à passer être
pauvre n'est pas une tare la pauvreté
est universelle tout de end de la façon
dont elle est partagée et dont la
solidarité s'organise autour de cette
pauvreté l'Afrique est pauvre mais
l'Afrique est digne digne pourquoi quand
il y a eu cet événement
rarissisme grave nous avons reçu des
instruction de la des autorités
maliennes de rester digne et de palier
justement au drame de ces familles-là de
les entourer et le gouvernement malien a
envoyé quatre ministres euh de vendredi
à samedi quatre ministres sont venus
dont un délégué spécialement qui
s'appelle monsieur dico qui est le
ministre des Maliens de l'extérieur
l'Afrique a changé l'Afrique évolue
parce que de en même temps que nous
sommes en train de faire cette émission
vous êtes regardé par des millions de
Maliens en direct ça il faut que les
gens le sachent l'Internet et puis les
médias actuels sont partout les
Africains regardent de partout donc
c'est moi c'est ce que j'ai dit euh il y
a le racisme il faut que les Français se
ressaisissent qui se disent que ces
Africains qui sont là qui sont
différents apportent aussi si vous
voulez un changement apporte de la
richesse parce que moi ce que j'ai
appris c'est mes ancêtres les Gaulois et
quand je suis là aujourd'hui c'est pour
m'exprimer en amitié et comme je partage
avec fatumata quand elle dit que euh les
Français ne sont pas racistes il faut
faire la part des choses tous les
Français ne sont pas racistes il y a des
Français qui sont ouverts mais il faut
qu'on se ressaisisse tous qu'on se dise
qu'on partage un patrimoine commun qui
s'appelle la culture française c'est ce
que je peux vous dire en réponse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]